In front of me is Grigol
Vashadze.
He is a Georgian politician.
He used to hold the position of the Minister
of Foreign Affairs under Mikhail Saakashvili
leadership and now he is a presidential candidate,
he is representing the opposition.
Mr. Vashadze, thank you for the interview
and welcome to the program.
Thank you very much.
- Very interesting fact about you is that
you for a number of years held dual citizenship
- Russian and Georgian but you renounced the
Russian in 2008.
Could you tell more why you decided to give
up your Russian citizenship?
- You know I used to have one passport, just
Russian passport.
I was residing in Moscow and I had been residing
there from 1976 to 1993.
When the Soviet Union collapsed in 1991, I
was in the United States of America.
I don’t remember for five or six months.
And when I came back I discovered that I am
a Russian citizen because Soviet Union didn't
exist.
Then we returned back to Georgia in 2004 and
I got my Georgian citizenship in 2005.
Or four.
Anyway, Four or five.
The end of 2004, the beginning of 2005.
And then now after the war, the Russian-Georgian
war I sent my passport to comrade Medvedev
and I said that I am renouncing my Russian
citizenship because I cannot tolerate attitude
of Kremlin towards independence of my country,
of my nation.
It took eleven months for Kremlin to decide
if they would like me to sweep me off of my
Russian citizenship but eventually they did.
And I am now a holder of just one passport,
of Georgian passport.
- Mr. Vashadze , there is going to be the
second round of the presidential elections
in Georgia.
And as a result of their first round you got
around thirty eight percent of voters’ support.
And the difference between you and your major
opponent is very insignificant.
Are you happy with the results?
- You know, this is official version of so-called
government and so-called Georgian Dream.
In reality I won the first round.
Quite frankly I would not speculate on how
much actually, what percentage actually so-called
Georgian Dream fixed at this election.
But the most modest estimate would be 15 percent.
Something like this.
Because Salome Zurabishvili respectfully she
is nobody.
Absolutely nobody.
It's out of question that thirty eight percent
of Georgians did vote for her.
If you just imagine the amount of money spent
by so-called Georgian Dream upon those elections
you are going...
It's a mind boggling figure.
- So we have unfortunately to rely on the
official data.
And I would like to ask to analyze these data
because do you think it's a sign, these results,
which were quite unexpected for the ruling
party, these results are a sign of your popularity
among Georgian citizens or it's a sign of
general weariness of the ruling party?
- Basically all of this.
Combination of all those reasons.
Because when on July the 20th of this year
eight of us, eight of us one of them is sitting
next to me here, eight of us jumped into two
cars and we started our forty three thousand
kilometer long journey around Georgia.
And we said right this time that we're going
to win these elections.
Second is that everybody knew me back from
my five years as the Minister for Foreign
Affairs of Georgia and they knew that I've
done a lot of things for this country.
That I designed and I brought to the successful
end the campaign of non-recognition of our
occupied regions.
Fifty eight states, we have established diplomatic
relations with 58 states we didn't have diplomatic
relations previously with.
I have signed a lot of important treaties
for my country including visa facilitation.
Without that agreement with the European Union,
the Schengen zone of the European Union we
could not be having visa liberalization now.
Then I can go on.
So they knew me and my reputation.
And the third reason is that Georgian citizen
is outraged.
Georgian citizen is very angry Georgian citizen
hates so-called Georgian Dream because Georgian
citizen has not been living so badly since
2004.
And they are not accustomed to live and being
submerged into corruption, crime economic
stagnation, total absence of working places.
One hundred fifty thousand kids are living
in hunger, not poverty, but in hunger.
They are going to bed hungry.
Every third citizen is unemployed in this
country.
Close to one million has left this country
since 2012.
- You are supported by the former president
of Georgia Mikhail Saakashvili.
He's one of your ardent supporters.
Do you think in the second round it's going
to be an advantage or a disadvantage?
- You know, everybody knows in Georgia that
I am absolutely independent and I was independent
when I was member of the cabinet from 2008
to 2012.
I was not even a member of the party.
I absolutely refused to enter and become the
member of this party because I had the extreme
amount of problems with party’s internal
policies.
And I've been expressing that.
As with President Saakashvili I will sum up
my attitude to him.
He is my friend.
As each and every sounded lucid Georgian citizen
I'm thankful to him that he has transformed
geographical area into a modern state.
He shall have a right to live in Georgia.
So he shall get back his Georgian citizenship.
If there are questions which our law-enforcing
agencies or our justice system have to ask
him he shall answer those questions.
And if he is going to have political future
or not, that's up to Georgian nation to decide.
- If you become president, you are going to
return his Georgian citizenship?
- Exactly I will.
- Are you going to pardon him?
- Yes I will.
But I am not going to pardon him I am going
to pardon all political prisoners.
And please don't omit this because some television
channels in Georgia they are cutting the second
part of this phrase out.
- I will not cut it.
- Of course you will not.
I will pardon President Saakashvil.
I will pardon all political prisoners.
I will pardon all women who did not commit
something beyond imagination and have kids
outside prison.
I'm going to do that extremely quickly.
Maybe first two or three months because I
know what's going on in prisons
- As a lawyer I want justice to prevail and
justice shall prevail because the third president
of Georgia shall have a right to live here.
If you're going to use these right or not
it's up to him.
Again it's up to him his political future
is up to Georgian people, Georgian citizens.
But to reside here in his small house in Guareli
- absolutely we owe to him that much.
- You mentioned that you are friends with
Saakashvili.
But he is absolutely remarkable because he
sometimes resorts to sharp criticism of his
former allies.
Do you think that a potential conflict between
you and him if you of course become president
is a workable scenario?
- You know, it is a strange question because
quite frankly I am not.
I have never been choosing my friends according
to their political beliefs.
- You both have political interests.
That's what I meant.
- Yes.
He's my friend and if there is a contradiction
between my beliefs and his beliefs I'll try
my best to retain our friendship.
But quite possibly our political paths will
part away.
I would not.
I would not start screaming like some of his
other friends to TV correspondents that Misha
Saakashvili is the only one to be blamed for
the mistakes.
That Misha Saakashvili is a dictator, Misha
Saakashvili was an obstacle when those guys
were doing all the job to transform Georgia.
To me it's ridiculous.
- He is not a dictator, he is a true democrat?
- He absolutely.
Which dictator ever staged peaceful transition
of power.
- Mr. Vashadze, you're absolutely right with
your great example of Mr. Saakashvili being
a true democrat that he ensured peaceful transition
of power.
It's out of question and I think it's one
of the fundamental things for Georgia to preserve
this democratic tradition.
But his critics say that when in power he
was extremely violent with his political opponents
that he put them in prison that there were
numerous violations of human rights.
There was a demonstration a peaceful demonstration
2007.
And he used some methods to disseminate this
demonstration.
What could you answer to this criticism?
- When we're speaking about mistakes we shall
differ mistakes from dictatorship.
Because if you would like to remember 2007.
Yes, it was a very sad occasion in our history
but again nobody was dispersing this crowd
incredibly large crowd in front of the parliament.
And they had constitutional right for assembly.
They had constitutional right to express their
opinion and for free speech.
I can tell you from my standpoint.
This raid that was exercised against and inside
TV IMEDI that was incredible mistake, political
mistake.
Incredible political mistake.
And I think that in many ways it was the beginning
of the end.
And my answer about Misha I could tell you
with 100 percent certainty that he is too
young to be written off.
But as each and every person who actually
did spend five or six years in immigration
he will have to accustom to this country from
the scratch, because this country has changed
and it has changed significantly.
- What do you mean under change?
Is Georgia still a democracy?
- It is
- It has become more democratic since Mr.
Saakashvili left
- No less democratic, it became less democratic
because if you check those facts of election
fixing, if you go through our TV market and
discover that there is only basically one
important independent TV station Rustavi-2.
If you go through Internet information hubs
and you discover that basically nearly 99
percent of them are controlled by so-called
Georgian Dream.
By Ivanishvili through all this.
Of course it's less democratic but the major
freedoms are here.
We have...
And Ivanishvili with his so-called Georgian
Dream is chicken pox.
Do you know what chicken pox?
Ветрянка.
Ветрянка, которой в детстве
болеют и вот переболеешь
and after three first days you're having temperatures
over 40 or 41.
Then after three days you are quickly recovering.
So we are having Ivanishvili as a chicken
pox.
- Mr. Vashzdze, returning to the presidential
election.
According to the current Georgian constitution
the role of the president is quite symbolic.
So it has effectively no executive powers.
Why are these elections important for you
personally and for the country?
- Yes, you would like to ask me why these
elections were so heated.
It's very correct and timely answer because
it's no not only presidential elections but,
it also most importantly, it's a referendum
on the future of our country.
Everybody understands that.
When we are winning not even when we are winning
those elections we are winning the referendum
on our country and we are bringing closer
snap parliamentary elections.
Everybody understands that, too.
Second it's utter nonsense that President
of Georgia is not going to have enough powers.
Excuse me, Supreme Commander of armed forces
much as far as I know it's a good point.
- But as far as I know.
It is a good point but you cannot execute
this even function without the consent of
the parliament or the government?
- Yes, it is Cardinal Richelieu, who used
to say: “Patience”.
- Ok
- Supreme Commander, the chief representative
of country in international relations.
Power of veto, power to approve Prime Minister,
power of pardon and a lot of other but most
important.
And don't forget, please.
There is a spirit of Constitution and there
is a letter of constitution.
Spirit of constitution means political process
and nobody can curb me to be head of the political
process.
I can see any government not only of so-called
Georgian Dream but any government, when I
ask 50 or 100 thousand my citizens to go out
in the street and join my protest for something.
Who is going to curb that right?
Just imagine yourself.
What kind of demonstration we're going to
stage.
So so-called Georgian Dream is very –very
right when they're fighting a deadly fight
for this post but they lost that fight.
- You mentioned a very interesting fact that
you think that these are not just presidential
elections.
This is a referendum about the future of the
country.
Now in the second round you and your opponent
Mrs. Zurabishvili are left.
If we do not focus on who supports whom you
are supported by Mikhail Saakashvili and his
political party whereas Zurabishvili is supported
by Ivanishvili and Georgian Dream.
What are their ideological differences between
you and your opponent?
I think that you agree on the western power
of the European path for Georgia on NATO accession
on everything.
- I am supported by I am supported trust me
by well over 40 percent of Georgian citizens.
This is the most important thing for me.
When it comes to differences I will tell you
what the differences are.
So-called Georgian Dream and their candidate
campaniero Zurabishvili, they think that everything
is wonderful in Georgia.
They think that the economic situation.
She has just said that the economic situation
is not that bad as you're describing it.
Not to me, to the audience and to journalists.
Ivanishvili thinks that everything was perfect.
I mean for five years he gave a paradise to
Georgian citizen.
Then suddenly he jumped out and said that
I have just discovered that one million are
living in poverty.
Whenever they got those outrageous reports
from the World Bank the United Nations and
UNICEF.
They are scared to death because they understand
Georgian citizens are deprived of all achievements
economic achievements which the government
gave to them from 2004 to 2012.
Country is submerging into extreme poverty.
This is the difference.
We are screaming that we shall abolish in
our budget all the luxuries.
Those stupid expenses which are made just
to win elections.
Financing all these all these soccer programs
and I don't know baseball team and Georgian
ice hockey team.
Can you imagine the idiocy of these?
When Ukrainian and Bulgarian hockey players
are playing in the fourth or fifth league.
I don't remember where.
We shall canalize all these money to health
care, to social assistance, to education and
to defense.
Otherwise we're going to disappear as a nation.
Our demography is catastrophic.
That's what we differ on.
And those excuse me my Georgian and those
idiots are proposing to this country marijuana
plantations is as a local motion for our economy.
In the 21st century is an epoch of economy
of knowledge.
When we shall jump on the train which is going
to the 22nd century otherwise we are going
to become for forever losers.
And I don't know.
Marginal state you know limiter of state.
They are calling our civil society our non-governmental
organizations fascists.
Those idiots do not even know meaning of this
word.
Do you know who is doing this?
- Ivanishvili, I know.
But he said that it was not a correct word
to use.
- What was correct?
Nazi?
- No-no-no.
He acknowledged that it wasn't.
It was the wrong thing to do.
That's what I wanted to say.
- But he said what he's thinking.
I don't care about his excuses and his partners.
I do not because they said that they're going
to bang opposition on the head.
The speaker of Parliament they have this Clockwork
Orange you know as a speaker of parliament
who said that he is going to bang opposition
on the head.
I'm very happy that he got banged on the head
after the first tour.
So that's where we differ.
- You have another major difference.
I don't want to talk about your differences
with Ivanishvili but we are talking about
you and your opponent.
And of course you have absolutely different
backgrounds.
You have a lot in common because Mr. Zurabishvili
used to hold the position of the Minister
of Foreign Affairs und also Saakashvili leadership.
She was before you.
She is a French career diplomat she was born
in France and you are a Soviet career diplomat.
Do you have problems with this?
- No.
I do not have any problems with it because
a person who was born in 1958 in Tbilisi you
couldn't be anything else.
So I was a Soviet diplomat and I can tell
you I am very proud of it.
Because I participated in negotiations which
made our life safer: prohibition of Chemical
Weapons and prohibition of nuclear tests.
And I went through a fantastic school.
I don't know what professional qualifications
of Zurabishvili are.
Excuse me.
But I shall repeat these words but when people
are saying in the street that I am the best
Minister for Foreign Affairs in our history
I'm very proud of it.
So-called Georgian Dream and Ivanishvili’s
TV stations they tried to play on this that
I am a KGB agent, I am Russia’s influence
agent.
I am this, I am that.
It Didn't work at all .
- If you win their elections.
What reaction on the part of the Russian government
do you expect?
- I spent five years of my life fighting with
Russia and I succeeded and left Russia in
a shameful company of Venezuela Syria Nicaragua
and no.
- So you're still going to meet with Putin
to discuss the future of the occupied territories?
То есть вы не планируете
встречаться с Путиным для
обсуждения будущего оккупированных
территорий?
- No.
No because I don't know what the reaction
of Kremlin is going to be.
I mean we are speaking about your country.
You're Russian.
Georgia by its independence took the strategic
role away from Russia itself in Caucuses.
And Russia is fighting to return that back.
But trouble is that two occupied regions,
they are not solving Russian problem at all.
They are suitcases without a handle you know
you can’t throw them away because it's a
shame.
You cannot keep them because you do not need
it.
You are just wasting your money upon it.
This is what's happening.
I don't know what the Kremlin's reaction is
going to be and quite frankly I don't care.
!!!!
- Who is your role model among present or
past world leaders?
- George.
Marshall.
- And why?
- This is the man who won the Second World
War.
Don't believe that Soviet Union could win
this war without the United States military
and logistical assistance.
You are.
You are young and they will be telling to
you that we could win this war alone.
Forget about it.
- Mr. Vashadze, I would like to thank you
for the interview and for your time.
- Thank you.
It was pleasure to be with you.